well i would say most recently i really
loved uh
some of the work that um
honey has been doing around values uh
that are encoded in machine learning
um
my my own uh team at google has been
or had been i guess
working on data genealogies
so really bringing
critical analyses into how machine
learning data is handled
and they have a few papers on that
um data and its discontents um
i really love that work obviously i'm
biased but because it was like my team
like my my direct reports i'm like very
proud of them or whatever but but it's
really fundamentally good work i think
i'm trying to think of like earlier
papers those are those are very recent
papers i think the earlier papers i'm
most interested in are ones that are
more reflective of what i was doing at
the time
so i really like the work of
herb clark
who was a psycholinguistics
communication person
and he did a lot of work that's
that's easily ported to computational
models about how humans communicate um i
just i really loved his work in my
thesis i like cite like
all of his work
um
so yeah that's i guess that would be a
good set
it's a great answer
and we can link to all those two in the
show notes which will be nice for people
to check out
you